caldwell-pope and Danny Green those are
the two to me X factors for the Lakers
of 18 combined DNA first foul goes on
Middleton marianas cleaning up on the
mess they're working around and screen
by Davis 83 the combo poses and finally
gets one to drop his first tonight in
Indianapolis a couple nights ago here at
the foyers team that team but bigots
lead for Milwaukee segundo started three
of six time out early in assists he is
not missed a game this season gotta
secure what
[Applause]
look at this deep dream here I mean this
is a couple of feet behind that
three-point line he had just previous
[Applause]
against the reigning MVP 3% for
Milwaukee here in this first half
[Applause]
this will take it right down the middle
of the lien and companions on miss the
pep now it's the hall has started
defensively for Frank Vogel and the
Lakers shake his hands on the triple
look at this three here and this is over
the length and David been a work in
progress
Brianna's three - three Green trying to
drive his way in Davis a floater card
count it in the foul and then here's the
running floater
[Applause]
picked up by Davis is so much late bill
ain't looking one way to feed the other
David's got a pant from the Brawn
teenage caldwell-pope shot clock at
three great defense to here by KC be
this of six gets a jump shot it's going
to be lights out because he has every
other tool and that's at three I would
love for him to get a mid-range game
because at the last 21 Eve's in the game
to roll broke triple to Davis over
traffic got it
that was over lo pans to never rainbow
that baby and pump fake there's the push
down low by Vince assists for James and
eight rebounds that is 14 screen McGee
here comes Davis spy Illya Silva and
institutions 11 now to build your way
out inside to bend and pretty nice Gumby
inside with a nice play 15 here in the
third watch it here contorts bending
leaning to look at the backup here
[Applause]
you got Yanis
looking like he's way our
[Applause]
full auditioning for the three-point
competition come all-star weekend 5 of 8
from down 10 of the season number one in
the NBA
Davis splits the defense and puts it
crew on those photos
the Rizzo to Davis and Davis over guys
very quick move there by Davis no loss
between him and
[Applause]
Mavis has 33 beautiful faith by ad
Western Conference Coach of the month
what time he's won it Vogel with
instructions to the Trimble into town
with 34 points and 11 rebounds with two
defenders right there he still sinks it
in it's a three bonds at the combo and
it's picked up by LeBron down
[Applause]
sledgehammer at the other end out racing
out to the tomb ball here's the pass
break to pass by LeBron and the finish
over Yanis here for ad